do you want to see my new favorite shape
yeah of course you do it's this one here
it's called the largest small hexagon
and i just love it because i love its
name the largest small hexagon so let's
break down what the name means so it's a
hexagon which is a six sided shape small
means that all the diagonals like corner
to corner they're all less than and
equal to one that's what small means and
then largest small hexagon means it has
the largest area with that rule if all
the diagonals are less than or equal to
one the idea is it could fit
in a
one by one box like that
in fact you could roll it around inside
that box and it would fit nicely in
there
what's surprising is it's not the
regular hexagon because that's what my
guess would have been okay what is the
largest area if you had all the
diagonals fitting inside a one by one
box and i would have guessed regular
hexagon
but it's not so it's this thing so this
is not a regular hexagon it's a regular
it has a larger area than the regular
hexagon by about four percent and this
was discovered in the 1970s by ron
graham so let me show you a little bit
more about this so i was surprised that
it wasn't a regular hexagon and if we
did um shapes with less sides it
actually is the regular shape
so for a triangle
the largest small triangle
is
the regular equilateral triangle these
have a side length one
and that would be your answer
for a quadrilateral
it is the square the square has
diagonals of one so it's not side length
one it's diagonals of length one that is
your largest small quad draw lateral
although there's more than one answer
for the quadrilateral because it could
be
any quadrilateral which has two
diagonals that are at right angles to
each other that have length one this has
length one and this has length one like
that if i put them like that that would
be a square but i could have a
quadrilateral of any sort of kite shape
like this and those would all have the
same answer they all have the same area
so they all count as the largest small
quadrilateral if you're looking at the
pentagon it's the regular pentagon so
here is the regular pentagon and then
your diagonals have length one and that
is the largest small
pentagon so therefore you think ah the
largest small hexagon
would be the regular hexagon
here it is but it turns out
it's not
so to solve this what ron grain did is
he used some graph theory which is a
little bit surprising graph theory is
the maths of points and networks so dots
and lines and he knew that some of these
diagonals had to have length one and he
just kind of looked at all the
possibilities and he drew them as graphs
he knew that some of these possibilities
were definitely not going to be the
largest area so you could get rid of
those and he had about
10 possibilities to go through and he
got rid of them he says no that doesn't
work and then with a few that he had
left he sort of wiggled the angles and
said well if i wiggle the angle does
that make it bit larger he worked on it
a bit longer and then he found
this shape so here it is again so this
is our
largest small hexagon but there is some
symmetry it's not the regular hexagon
but there is some symmetry to this it
looks like a pentagon it does look like
a pencil there's a kind kind of a reason
why it looks like a pentagon let me show
you so the way it's being constructed
actually is it's this shape this is a
pentagon where all the diagonals are
equal to one and then for the hexagon
all we've done is we've taken a vertical
line down here of length one and we've
added an extra corner to the bottom of
this pentagon so that's kind of the
shape
of the largest small hexagon so then ron
gray and said are the other
shapes that have even number side is
that the same kind of idea for that that
was his conjecture
well we didn't prove that for a long
time the octagon took another 30 years
to prove
and we did we proved it
so the octagon isn't the regular octagon
but it is this shape here here we have
our largest small octagon and it was
made the same way so started with a
seven-sided shape like this all the
diagonals have length one add on one
more diagonal and a little extra corner
to the bottom there and that's why we
get our octagon and then only recently
2007 we we were able to prove that this
is true so for the even sided shapes
this is how you construct the largest
small
shape want even more hexagons we'll go
get them at brilliant today's episode
sponsor
brilliance full of courses quizzes and
problems to sharpen your brain to lift
your game
everything's interactive as you can see
here and designed with loving care
it's made to make you smarter but also
put a smile on your face
whether you're a beginner or a veteran a
school student or a lifelong learner
brilliant has more than enough stuff to
keep you busy
already a subscriber then why not give
brilliant as a gift
by the way get 20 off a premium
all-inclusive subscription by going to
brilliant.org
number five details and a link can be
found down in the video description
[Music]